[Musique]
dans son fief dit ce matin philippe
grand le directeur de la société
martiniquaise des eaux bonjour monsieur
grands je me suis bien tombé
ainsi donc le préfet de martinique a été
saisi sur un contentieux que vous avez
sur vous avez avec le dc qui distribue
l'eau sur le territoire de l'acca ce
thème une facture de 10 millions d'euros
pour des impayés depuis plusieurs années
sauf que sauf que félix grande audi si
on a eu son directeur général ici-même
avant-hier jus de christine qui parlent
de chiffres fantaisistes 10 millions et
pourquoi pas 20 30 40 50 pendant qu'on y
est
qu'est ce que vous dites les choses sont
très claires de l'autre côté le prix de
l'eau est fiché par la collectivité donc
aujourd'hui nous avons un contre un ce
prix est fixé à 85 centimes on comprend
donc ce n'est pas quelque chose que nous
pouvons négocier un autre niveau
donc il a tout faux lorsqu'il dit que
c'est un chiffre fantaisiste absolument
aujourd'hui comment et fixer le prix du
lait fixé par la collectivité par notre
contrat on voit bien la posture en tout
cas de odissi sur ce sujet le prix qui
est fixé dans le contrat de 87 centimes
le mètre cube
ce prix a été d'ailleurs confirmé par la
chambre régionale des comptes suite au
litige que nous avons soulevé avec le 6
en 2015 une négociation ait lieu entre
les acteurs sur la base de 60 centimes
négociations dont je rappelle qui a été
menée sans la présence de l'asm
ce prix a été je dirais versée
autour de 2015 aujourd'hui quand on
écoute mais je pas quitte sur les ondes
une partie de l'eau d'ici le président
de ici nous parle de 20 centimes quand
j'écoute
j'ai écouté chevauchant de monsieur
jules christine sur sur ce plateau nous
annoncer un prix de 15 centimes comme
vous dites pourquoi pas 1 0 et
aujourd'hui c'est zéro nous ne sommes
pas payés
il n'y a pas que ça qui contestait par
audi si ils ne comprennent pas les
volumes que vous présentez il ne
comprend pas le prix de ces taux côté sa
sortie ça sort d'où ces chiffres-là nord
alors quand on a des volumes il faut
être très clair des compteurs ont été
mis en place aux limites du lamentin de
saint joseph 1 donc je rappelle que
effectivement assez me fournit l'eau
potable tous les jours aux habitants de
la montagne à genève car la cacem n'a
pas les ressources donc dans notre
contrat ces conditions sont prévues dans
les conditions tarifaires que je vous
indique justement décidé les compteurs
sont là mais on n'a aucun contrôle là
dessus vous pouvez d en dire ce que vous
voulez comme vous vous lancez pas si
derrière le compteur ya pas une
dérivation qui alimenterait d'autres
zones alors je vous remercie poser la
question c'est quand on a été posée
l'été 2010 est
nous avons invité les élus d'eau d'ici
nous avons invité à cas c'est là que ça
m'est venu les voir
ouais je n'ai pas compris franchement
pourquoi aucun collaborateur de 10,6
n'est venu les voir 60/40 vous seriez
prennent leur dire voici où sont les
compteurs je vous leur permet triés par
exemple de de regarder le suivi le tracé
de sonia d'alsace mais bien entendu
monsieur lieu temps nous souhaitons une
transparence totale sur ce sujet les
fonctions exécutives et de manque de
transparence
absolument et ça moi à la limite ça me
va bien ces valeurs là je veux de la
clarté je la transparence veut de
l'honnêteté il ya dix coureurs qui ont
été posées nous avons invité monsieur
jus de christine et ses collaborateurs à
venir les constater ces compteurs sont
en place je leur ai même donné un accès
aux données à distance
ils ne sont pas venus le chercher
aujourd'hui ces codes d'accès sont
toujours chez nous pour s'accroissent de
la posture tout cela qu'est ce qui
justifierait cette posture mais de part
et d'autre écoutez j'avoue que je ne
comprends pas cette position d'autant
plus que ces données
deux mesures sont des données à mon avis
intéressante pour l'exploitation donc
quand je les regarde ces données je
m'aperçois non seulement qu'elles ont
très fortement augmenté pour donner un
exemple aujourd'hui on produit 14 mille
tonnes d'eau ont fourni 14 mille tonnes
d'eau chaque jour au lamentin et saint
joseph
donc évidemment après un peu de
constance contester le prix mais quant
au volume celui ci il est mesuré par des
conteurs rouge à lui alors si vous voyez
que les contournements de 20%
il faut quand même s'interroger
aujourd'hui pourquoi les compteurs
augmente de 20%
on peut discuter du prix mais abandonné
faudra bien payer les volumes qui passe
ces compteurs sont les compteurs à gré
c'est pas des compteurs qui sont une
estimation et j'ai entendu monsieur jus
de christine nous critiquer aussi
l'appel avant les compteurs ces comptes
ont été posées à 1 environ
comment avons-nous facture et je dirais
la période antérieure
on va facturer sur les données connues
en 2014 aujourd'hui si je regarde les
volumes consommés réellement parler
contart ils sont 20% supérieur à
l'estimation
alors tout ça c'est encore l avantage du
dc qu'est ce que vous dites au dc
lorsqu'il laisse comprendre que
peut-être que l'argent qu'on demande
aujourd'hui à saint joseph et au
lamentin c'est peut-être pour compenser
les factures d'autres communes notamment
celles du sud alors écoutez ça c'est un
débat que j'entends toujours sur les
ondes
je ne peux pas y souscrire très
clairement aujourd'hui on fournit de
l'eau
on fournit de l'eau aux usagers ce prix
comme je voulais deal est fixé par le
contrat
donc à partir de ce moment là je dirais
la prestation et du aujourd'hui
clairement vous fournissez 14 mille
mètres cubes
si j'écoute je vais je vais rebondir
l'envers monsieur jus de christine dans
son dans son intervention sur votre
plateau disait vouloir payer qu'un
centime selon une note qui émanerait de
la société martiniquaise des eaux elle
même dont vous êtes le directeur général
alors vous savez quand on évalue les
coûts on peut évaluer les coûts de
revient les coûts des produits les coûts
des services qu'on vous produisez un
service auto prenant compte un don vous
prenez le produit le brut vous la
traitez vous la fournissent et vous
mettez d'énergie vous mettez les réseaux
derrière vous avez des supports vous
avez la facturation des contrôles des
lignes de télécommunication tout ça il
faut les ajouté et très clairement
aujourd'hui moi ce que je constate
je regarde quand monsieur je juge
christine 10 sur les antennes que l'asm
fait 550 % de marge
il fait référence justement à ces cas
centimes vous me les factures et
beaucoup plus 1 d'abord un je ne suis
pas d'accord parce que les 87 centimes
sont pas des montants qui reviennent
intégralement l'asm dans les 87 centimes
il ya des taxes il ya les rucks et
antisociaux il ya les renault et a aussi
des taxes c'est à dire que il ya la part
de l'asm eux qui représentent environ 60
centimes
mais il ya aussi à part des
collectivités il ya la peur de l'eau d
eux savaient qu'ils collectent pour les
subventions il officie à l'eau voilà le
fils de l'eau il y à aussi je dirais le
3r la tva tous assez pris en compte sur
la facture c'est pas des bénéfices
accusé audi siège de christine d'avoir
regardé tout simplement que la simple
production de l'eau est pas tout ce qui
va avec
d'une part et puis d'autre part je crois
qu'il a comparée des prix hors taxes et
des prix ttc je suis désolé mais ce
n'est pas tout à fait honnête
alors vous vous demandez où est passé
cet argent ce différentiel entre les 87
centimes et
et ces fameux 20 centimes que
réclamerait donc au disick justifierait
donc au dc où est allé cet argent si
vous posez la question ce qui quelque
part vous avez peut-être déjà la réponse
alors écoutez j'ai appris sur vos ondes
d'ailleurs que monsieur pas quitte le
président nous dise y est nous dit avoir
mis l'argent de côté sur un compte
bloqué chambre des dépôts et
consignations donc moi je l' ai
découvert je ne savais pas en attendant
le règlement du contentieux
c'est ce qu'il a dit alors aujourd'hui
tout à l'heure je dirige évoqués le
bénéfice de ce soi-disant 550% moi
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas touché un
centime de tous évolué et pour cause
depuis le contentieux est en cours
depuis deux ans et demi
rendez vous quand on fournit 10 mille
litres 10 mille bouteilles d'eau par
minute aux usagers du lamentin saint
joseph pour pas un centime ça veut dire
quoi ça en termes de coûts ça veut dire
que c'est pas un bénéfice c'est une
perte moi aujourd'hui
comme vous l'avez compris j'ai du
personnel j'achète de l'eau je fournis
je n'ai pas un centime
donc c'est pas un bénéfice de 550 points
c'est une perte pour la cemac philippe
grand l'argent est déposé à la chambre
des dépôts et consignations si on en
croit au dc en attendant le règlement de
ce dossier or il se trouve que les
services de l'état ont été a été
sollicitée à travers une commission
chargée de déterminer le prix exact de
l'eau en martinique
et là encore vous l'avez entendu justin
a dit qu'il ya eu un manque de
transparence lors de notamment de la
transmission de certains dossiers donc
cette commission ne peut pas travailler
pourquoi vous ne transmettez pas les
papiers selon elle merci pour la
question
il fait référence à un groupe de travail
qui a été animée par le préfet dans
cette logique là nous n'avons pas été
invités
nous n'avons même pas été invité autour
de la table alors comment voulez vous
bien de la part du préfet comment voulez
vous fournir des éléments je dirais sans
avoir été associés et sans savoir ce
s'est tenu dans cette raison très
clairement oui
aujourd'hui quand j'évoquais tout à
l'heure pour donner un autre exemple la
négociation qu'il y a eu sur les prix de
l'eau en 2015
quatre présidents se sont réunis les
collectivités on comprend cap nord et
spacieux
kacem mais aussi le président de ici en
revanche le président le dsm eux n'a pas
figuré auto la table trouvez vous ça
normal
on trouvait ça normal quand on parle de
transparence
oui on dit qu'on ne fournit pas les
donner mais en tout cas en tout cas on
nous met de côté
oui c'est ce que je constate et on vous
prête du droit encore concernant la
question de l'assainissement vous avez
entendu ce qu'il a dit concernant la
station d'épuration au niveau de gags de
la galleria qui fatigue qui agace qui
énerve beaucoup d'automobilistes qui
passe dans la zone
vous n'avez pas fait le job à écouter je
passe tous les jours aussi dans cette
zone là pour me rendre compte que ça ne
vous dérange pas d'avoir quitté station
d'épuration qui n'a pas été fait aux
normes très très clairement cette
situation d'odeurs de nuisance me
dérange fortement est en tout cas
aujourd'hui
si on regarde les entorses et directeur
général n'avait pas envie d'appeler vos
services pour dire les gars pourquoi
vous pétez fans
alors écoutez le job a été fait si vous
regardez nous avons transféré la gestion
de cette station qui est à côté de la
gallery relaxation d'acajou à ou dc qui
la gère depuis cinq ans nous l'avons
gérer avant y avait-il des odeurs y
avait-il des problèmes à l'époque c'est
une nation que vous n'êtes qu'on connaît
bien une sachant qu'on gérait pour
lequel on renouvelait le matériel
aujourd'hui bizarrement depuis cinq ans
il ya des odeurs qu'apparaissent
pourquoi la smt serait responsable de
cette apparition subite
est ce qu'il y avait autant de problèmes
d'odeurs à l'époque moi aujourd'hui je
n'étais pas là je ne peux pas juger je
laisse en tout cas les riverains en
parler c'est eux qui connaissent mieux
le sujet donc moi ce que je vois en tout
cas pour donner un exemple concret
soyons transparents monsieur jus de
crise il nous a appelé ses services nous
ont appelés fin décembre 2010 est maudit
est ce que vous pouvez pas nous mettre à
disposition deux hydro éjecteur pour les
aider à supprimer une odeur on l'a fait
on l'a fait rapidement on n'est pas venu
s'en glorifier sur le plateau on n'a pas
non plus facturer ces de l'entr'aide
l'entr'aide en cas de sinistre
l'entr'aide en cas de situation
aujourd'hui moi je note en tout cas on
essaye d'apporter notre soutien
ça semble pas très rock
ce n'est pas un manque de communication
tout simplement entre les services
écoutez anti surprendre en dix heures
d'entraînement
bon je crois qu'on peut toujours
communiquer je vous remercie de nous
inviter c'est dans ce sens là que l'on
peut je dirais éclairer les auditeurs
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nos
philippe grand rapids et directeur
général de la société martiniquaise des
eaux bonnes journées